[Musik]
ist es Ego ist nur ein Illusion
er wurde das alles Eis alles mit allem
verbunden was ist spirituelle Weisheit
über das reden hört
[Musik]
ja heute einmal zu einer neuen Folge
zum Thema Meditation Spiritualität und
Yoga und zum im ufertal in einer
schweizhütte reden
sondern
ich versuche eigentlich so alle
achtsamkeitsbewegung
konzentriere aber ich mache das nicht
ich als
regelmäßig machen
[Musik]
genau
Meditation die Achtsamkeit bewegen
Spezialisten
Philosophie Hinduismus und diese
Kollegen interessant gemacht zum Thema
Yoga und da wo er das ganze Hund was
verschiedene
die Sehnsucht in der heutigen Zeit warum
ist das so eine riesen Trend wurde mit
dem maturikergerät oder mit dem John
Cover Zinn das sind so
Gründer und und Vorreiter in ganze
Bereich
es geht wie beide Strömungen es geht
einerseits die wo wirklich ein
spirituelle Wagen
der sehr materialistische
individualistische Welt wo Fleisch die
du verfolgt trinktisch
Dimension finde vielleicht Ersatz für
Religionen wo zum Teil aus der Welt
und die andere wo man sich fragen wie
kann ich mir Resilienz steigern wie kann
ich irgendwie noch fitter sie und zwar
mental
merkfähigkeiten
Qualität und so weiter genau und es geht
auf Tatsache zeigen
muss ich sagen
viel so Artikel gegeben
und Patienten
[Musik]
eigentlich jedes Personalstelle dass
jeder widrigsten Umstand irgendwie nur
leistungsfähig bleiben und ich glaube
der Vorwurf der morgen aber das ist auch
wiederum überzogen also ich glaube das
machen
und gegen die Zerstreuung und der Stress
und so weiter und gleichzeitig versuchen
irgendwie engagiert sie und Verhältnis
verhandeln
und die mystische Erfahrungen nicht nur
mit Meditation sondern zum Teil auch mit
Naturerfahrungen
also
transzendentanzeigenschaft stimmt es
immer noch Bedürfnis sie sich irgendwie
verurte ist immer größere ganze und
andere Transformation also wenn all die
Trips dein geschaut und andere Sachen
also Druck konsumiere und irgendwie ein
Erfahrung von Fleisch anders
transformationsverfahren
und andere sind mir
etwas Bedürfnis noch Klarheit
also es gibt zum Beispiel Alter
trendkohl mit trinken zum Beispiel drei
general oder januar und die Meditation
verspricht ja also sie Klarheit
Bewegungen nicht drum dass man ein
bisschen
erzwingen du trainierst von Marathon
bestimmt schneller sondern es muss auch
ein bisschen wo du dich öffnest und dann
passiert und das ist nicht passiv und
das finde ich wichtig die unterscheidigt
Yoga Meditation spiritualität ist nichts
zu tun sondern nicht zu tun und denn
nicht tun ich habe gesagt aktiv während
der nicht machen nichts tun ist passiv
also es braucht extrem viel übrig und
Disziplin nur dort sitzen und sich nur
darauf atmen konzentriere also
du nicht tun aber trotzdem ist es auch
der öffnen und dann passiert ob es mit
dir das ist im großen Unterschied das
sind einfach Körpertechniken
Stunde tagelang
monatelang jahrelang oder klar passiert
den App ist du kannst es nicht erzwingen
aber es ist sozusagen wie keine Vorhang
trainieren
ja kann Meditation ein Weg von der
Erkenntnisse
frag Meditation nicht nur das
Entspannung
als Mittel zur Konzentration sondern das
weg von der Erkenntnis und Filly wo
regelmäßig meditieren beschrieben
noch eine Achtsamkeit Meditation hat
dass man eigentlich Gedanken und Gefühl
ist sich gespürt wahrnimmt aber sie
lautlos wie verbinde
deine identifiziert nicht eine haftet
und dann irgendwie plötzlich ein reinere
Form vor bewusst sie spürt und erlaubt
und sich mit dem allgemeinen
universeller oder Bewusstsein
identifizieren und das immer total
spannende
gedankenkultur fehlt die mystische
Traditionen die mystische All-Einheit
aber heute rechtliche Philosophie die
Idee dass ich Vernunft und waldvernunft
eben jetzt Zusammenhang mit und ich
glaube wirklich wenn so ein bisschen
dazu und es ist genau die Seite sind
unterschiedliche Stufen man kann einfach
meditieren achtsamkeitsbewegung zum
Beispiel einfach zum zur
Distanz finden zu den eigenen Gefühlen
zum Beispiel also die ist echt dass ich
nicht meine Angst bin
zum Beispiel die andere Idee das ist so
es geht in der Welt zählen das ist wie
du siehst sehr verbreitet die der
hinduistische Philosophie heißt das
Brahman die kosmische Energie die alle
Seele Welt zählen es gibt ganz viele
Übersetzungen und dann geht er in den
Sprache zu Braumann dass ich atmen die
Weltseele Ideen konzentriert und wenn du
der Weg nach innen machst und Zugang zu
Hause
das ist die Idee hinter draußen
wo mehr sind wo dann aber ist mehr
zurück
Individualität mich Ergometer
der merken wir dass das gar nicht
gesehen
ja bis größerem ganzen und aber wirklich
auch die Vorstellung ist steil vor bis
größerem ganzen das
Zugehörigkeitsgefühl und interessant
finde ich aber man nimmt oft Bezug den
auf buddhistischen Traditionen
hinduistische Traditionen
irgendwie ganz einfach
Theologie oder Philosophie aus äußern
also ich finde z.B immer wieder
interessant Sachen als Logo von Meister
Eckert ein Theologe oder Philosoph aus
dem 14 Jahrhundert und die Idee hat vom
Seelen fünf klein unterscheide
beschrieben hast also alles drin ist
eigentlich
Gott oder das allprinzip oder die
mutterkraft oder wie immer der
allgegenwärtige Geist schwimmen das wird
schneller
das ist immer schon da gesehen also das
ist weder erschaffen nur erschaffbar und
genau aus dem Grund
warum
jeden einzelnen von euch erschafft und
auch mit der Idee dass du zu mir
Sprechen
das ist immer schon wieder innen und ich
sie allen innen ich kann mit dem weniger
christliche Tradition aus verschiedenen
gegründet ich finde aber die
buddhistische Bilder für mich ein
unglaublich so wirklich ich bin der
prospirituell irgendwie hoch musikalisch
ist im Gegenteil aber ich finde das ist
ein bisschen danke Wetter Wiener Schule
was du eigentlich traurig ist ich bin
Skeptiker so ich denke natürlich dann
immer okay in der Meditation in dem
Zustand sind die nicht diskern anders
ich kann natürlich also quasi mystische
Erfahrungen irgendwie in extremen
Zustand in der Schweiz heute zum
Beispiel oder irgendwie mit Drogen oder
was auch immer aber was berechtigte dich
das Verfahren zeigen
gefragt trifft mich auch um und gerade
wenn du von deiner Extase verzählst
Schwitzhütte und die drogeninduziert
oder Substanz induzierte Zustand die
fragt man sich das ja auch wenn du ein
LSD-Trip machst und du gesehen mit Wald
ganz bunt ist dass die achte Welt oder
ist das hirnkino
extrem gut gefallen
alle Welt und alles ist mit allem durch
Trank ist alles miteinander verbunden
das schöne große Frage also die
spirituelle Erlebnis die quasi mystische
Erlebnissen oft Erlebnis wo man merkt
mehrere ganze und alles ist miteinander
verbunden
[Gelächter]
mit mit Tücher
aber es ist sehr ritualisiert also und
bei jedem Stein
alles ist mit allem verwandt wirklich
ein schönes maltraum und
Versuchsleiterin
Bilder natürlich evoziert und gesagt
naturos oder sind dir der Mond am Himmel
und so weiter und er versucht wirklich
all die bezügt nichts verurteilt und die
fetzig herstellen wo du den Augen
bis realistisch also wenn Du Dir mal
überleisch weißt du zusammen wie sehr
mir auch abhängig gewesen sind also mir
tragen da weiß nicht wie viel
kilobaktere mit dieser mikrobiom alle
Energie-
also das führt womit macht ein aus dem
Holz nachher die Energie mit den Steinen
auch mir sind nicht anders die Sterne
Staub so schön
zum Beispiel sind oder die Verbundenheit
die Vorstellung es gibt auch keine neue
Elemente also all diese Sachen wo mir
das künstlich bezeichnet sind
letztendlich natürlich im
nicht präsent die allermeisten
ganz naturwissenschaftlich gewandertheit
schon wirklich viel mehr das ganze es
kosmisches Prinzip ist wo man sehr viel
grösser ist und ganz egal wie man es
jetzt wandert ob es jetzt mehr materiell
tankt oder mir das geistige denkt ich
glaube die Idee von der wunderheide
Soziologie
sehr berührt sie sind von dem
Sprache nur noch
mal interviewt und die Retter bleiben im
7 Teil über das Geier Prinzip das Buch
sie haben Natur
verzählt das verhindern Unterschied
macht dann können wir noch über
Gewalt der Planet
Dirt Menschen als Verbundenheit also ein
bisschen
verwoben und abhängig
genau und das geht euch auch spezielle
Verantwortung dafür und ich glaube
tatsächlich es gibt viele so spirituelle
Bewegungen
optimieren
Meditationspraxis in Buddhismus
spezielle Arten von Meditation
genau
Versuche genau die Empathie das
Mitgefühl oder die Form von Perspektive
bewusst machen dass das andere Teil von
mir ist und und umgekehrt der Gedanke
kultiviere und ich glaube dass das
veränderte natürlich
zu verhalten und ich glaube mit
unbedingt nur sagen der Umkehrschluss
stimmt natürlich nicht die Leute
die Verbundenheit wo gar nicht
spirituell sind könnt trotzdem
selbstverständlich sehr viel
Verantwortung übernehmen für Umwelt für
Natur und so weiter also es ist kein
irgendwie jetzt these in die andere
Richtung
dass die Sehnsucht nach Verbundenheit
noch einmal sind alleinheit mit dieser
individualistische Zeit ja weil
Erkenntnisse mit Hilfe von Meditation
oder einfach Yoga schrieben sie
Kommentare und wenn er mehr zum Thema
wenn du zwei Sprache heißt zum Thema
Sehnsucht exakt mit dem Auto und
Künstler James